[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive uh in the
next half hour we'll be seeing what's
making the headlines with the editor of
the nottingham shirt live natalie fay we
were hoping also to be connected with
deputy news editor of conservative home
henry hill we're still trying to
establish those connections so for now
natalie and i will be going uh through
those papers let's have a look at some
of the front pages
the daily telegraph reports on
accusations that vladimir putin has
ordered the abduction of thousands of
ukrainians from mariupol forcibly
deporting them to remote russian cities
the guardian also leads with that uh
with the u.s ambassador to the u.n
saying if those reports are true that
it's disturbing and unconscionable
well ukraine's president is accusing
vladimir putin of crimes that will be
remembered for centuries that is on the
front of the metro
the financial times that focuses on
russia's bombing of an art school saying
that intense fighting is taking place
across mario paul
the eye carries a harrowing message from
a ukrainian citizen our neighbours want
us dead
the sun goes with calls for the
chancellor to cut fuel duty
there's also on that is also on the
front of the express which says rishi
sunak knows record pump prices are one
of the biggest bills people face and
pledged to make a difference
and the mirror reports on the deadline
for pno bosses to explain the decision
to sack 800 workers uh and a reminder
that by scanning the qr code you'll see
on screen during the program you can
check out the front pages of tomorrow's
papers while you're watching us
uh well as i said tonight we are joined
uh by natalie fay so let's get straight
into uh the papers uh natalie thanks for
being with us tonight i'm sorry we
haven't got henry for now we will keep
trying to get back to him
but let's let's begin with the front of
the metro uh and that really quite a
resting uh headline crime of the
centuries i mean they detail their
the crimes that they're talking about
the bombing of an art school with 400 uh
people said to be sheltering inside it
and mario paul amongst them children uh
and and women
and then a care home coming under fire
from a tank in cremina
and then ukrainians uh being deported
from mario paul to uh remote places in
russia i mean there's even the word
terrorism here used by the metro
does that give us a sense here that
globally speaking in terms of the moral
uh war
putin has lost that or is this you know
just our western echo chambers saying
that and actually if you look at uh
papers in india we might be finding it a
completely different story
no well i really feel like there's some
really worrying lines that have merged
over the past 24 hours and you pulled
out the main the three main ones there
russia just seems to be absolutely going
for you know the elderly at the care
home
young people people sheltering and
hiding trying to get away and just
innocent civilians
um it absolutely seems that they're just
they're just going for the jugular now
and and this is it and we'll see in a
few of the other papers later that
they're asking for the surrender of
mario paul at five o'clock tomorrow
morning
so really now what is there left i mean
uh uh you've got president zielenski
there bravely coming out with his i mean
he's been brilliant throughout the whole
of this hasn't he what he's saying there
crime of sentries he's grabbing the
headlines he's trying to get the
international support he needs for the
people who haven't given it yet and
there are still a few countries who
haven't
um but it really feels like you know
what else could russia possibly do now
where can they go next we're seeing all
these horrendous images of war-torn
cities blackened buildings people
walking along with trolleys and carrier
bags just desperately trying to get out
of the country where do we go next with
this
well i guess that where can they go next
would be for many would be chemical
weapons as they did uh in syria which of
course the world is waiting for
i mean are you in any doubt
obviously i know you haven't firsthand
seen the evidence but are you in any
doubt seeing what you're seeing uh that
war crimes are being committed by the
russians here
um yes i mean it seems like it i mean we
saw right at the beginning they were
using cluster bombs and um you know now
they're just completely going for
children women people trying to take
shelter from things
they're not offering people any way out
um putin's already hugely isolated on
the world stage
um psychopathic i think would be the
word we'd probably use he doesn't seem
to care um how can anyone hold into
account now we've had list liz trust
coming out saying well we are going to
hold russia to account but how
what else can we possibly do
um well we haven't seen it it's
interesting that because we had a i
spoke to a ukrainian member of
parliament earlier tonight who said
well the sanctions can be toughened up
still that all trade with russia could
be brought to an end as poland has been
has been uh calling for
obviously cutting off all oil and gas
from russia all trade
and then of course this highly
contentious no-fly zone that nato has
rebuffed time and time and time again uh
because of course it would put it
potentially into direct conflict with
russia but this idea that there is still
more to do
yeah and i suppose that's right um but
you know
who how how many more people are going
to suffer um when this happens you know
by the time this happens
we've already seen that 10 million
people have fled the country
um thousands of people have died
innocent people
so what is the price what's gonna how
can where can we go next
let's have a look at the front of the
daily telegraph russia russians accused
of mass abductions
this is that uh third point that we were
talking about from the front of the
metro the the uh
deportation of uh ukrainians from
mariopol to places in russia and there's
a bit of detail on the type of places
they're being taken to
and the fact that they're being told
that they might have to stay there for
two years i mean it is shocking isn't it
yeah well this has all got really these
are claims made by mario paul city
council so obviously they've not been
verified yet
but they are being widely reported
everywhere
but
what they're saying is happening is that
ukrainians are being taken to
what they're likening to concentration
or prison camps and obviously
um there's strong overtones there of
what happened in world war two
um and being made to work for free for
up to two years in sort of remote
russian cities
uh now of course it's important to
stress that none of these reports are
verified but you know liz trust has also
commented on it she said that she was
appalled by the russian
atrocities um and what's going on and
saying that putin is reporting desperate
measures
um
so
it's it's interest it's an interesting
tactic it's also on the front page of
the guardian thousands from mario paul
being forced into russia and it's
interesting because if we take away i
mean as you say these are still
unsubstantiated uh allegations we don't
know yet what's going on but even if we
imagine that there are busloads of
ukrainians being taken to russia that is
akin also to what happened uh in
lithuania uh
when the soviets tried to take over
lithuania and there's this sense that
perhaps if they can remove some of the
ukrainian population take them over to
russia
that perhaps from the russian
perspective they think they have more of
a chance of taking
the hearts and minds if you like of uh
ukraine which at the moment they are
absolutely failing to do the ukrainian
resistance has shown itself to be uh
extremely strong stronger than certainly
than putin uh
could have estimated and stronger i
think than most of the world would have
thought i wonder if you have
ukrainians
in russia doesn't matter where they are
might they be able to bring
real news to the russians who are
currently fed on a diet of propaganda if
if we imagine they're not in
concentration camps and they're allowed
to mix in society
um they could very well they could very
well do yes i mean um they could bring
them you know the actual horrors of what
they've seen there
but it's interesting you mentioned that
by removing the ukrainian people um
that's going to take away the kind of
strength that we've seen so far from the
people in those countries because you
know that's been the main thing that's
come through to me out of all of this
the people have just sort of taken on
arms themselves they've blocked the
bridges themselves
um even if they're not trained to do so
they're absolutely adamant that they're
not going to give up their country and
so literally by forcing all the people
out taking them out of the country um
just weakening that very strength of the
population that we've seen there
um
so
but but yes they will bring the news out
with them
uh but and that will bring that out to
the russian people but i do think a lot
of russian people already know what's
going on anyway we've seen from some of
the protests there they don't back putin
with what he's doing
well it's interesting it's interesting
that isn't it because it's
it seems to be very generationally split
split so those who are younger and able
to access the internet and able to find
their way through
uh the various bits of censorship that
there are online are able to get
information that allows them to
have a viewpoint that would put them out
on the streets and protest whereas there
is an enormous percentage of the
population particularly the sort of 40
plus who are fed a diet of state
television and state media and and do
support uh putin i mean we saw a rally
uh the day before yesterday uh in which
putin's supporters all around him
cheering for uh his
not war they don't call it a war there
but for his uh
for his campaign in uh ukraine
so it's not that that you know russians
are blind to the fact that they they are
just being fed a diet of propaganda
let's look at this other story on the
front of the guardian here zelensky
likens putin to nazis in appeal for
israeli help i mean there is
a huge hypocrisy and irony here isn't
there uh in the fact that uh that putin
has been calling for the denuncification
of ukraine from the beginning a country
that is led by
a jewish president and a jewish prime
minister
yes and i read that um you know israel
can only put sanctions on a country
unless it formally declares it as an
enemy which it hasn't done so far for
various reasons and so far is trying to
play this kind of mediator role in the
whole thing which is obviously not
working in the slightest um but you know
um president zielenski needs all the
support he can get and speaking as a
jewish person
he's appealing to the israelis and
saying right you need to help me out now
with some sanctions
um and he spoke to their parliament via
video link and warned that indifference
could cost lives and there was no
mediating between good and evil and
absolutely challenged them over the lack
of sanctions and the failure um to come
to their aid with weapons
what effect that will have i'm not
really sure at the moment but surely
israel needs to come out
on the right side yeah he's drawn these
comparisons between uh the final
vladimir putin's final solution for
ukraine and the nazi extermination of
the jews
how useful do you think these second
world war analogies are we've heard so
many of them across the piece uh for
this war in ukraine do you think they
they are useful
i think they're useful because you
immediately know um what you're talking
about you know everybody knows what
happened in world war ii and that's
useful for zelinski because he needs
that support he needs to get the
headlines he needs to grab the attention
of world leaders at the moment for that
support
um
it is it is quite similar what's
happening yes um you know and i i do
think that's that's probably quite
useful for him to do that and it's
especially
emotional for him because he is a jewish
person
and so that's something he identifies
with probably people in his family in
the past who suffered in world war ii
and he can see that happening to his own
people again so why would he not use
that analogy
and as you say you've been sort of
mentioning it throughout that you know
if there's one thing zelinski really has
shown himself to be expert at it is
gaining control of the narrative and and
managing to uh push through uh on the
information wall uh when it comes to it
natalie we're gonna have to leave it
there because we are uh heading into the
break but we will be back uh with you
shortly
let us take a look uh no we will take we
will take a look at the weather